also breaking tonight in Henderson the
Clark County coroner says the death of a
Henderson inmate while in custody back
in March was due to the use of force
from officers his death being called a
homicide Henderson Police say
53-year-old Ronald Winborn pointed a
knife at officers on March 21st forcing
them to deploy tasers when born was
treated at Saint Rose De Lima Hospital
right afterwards later taken to the
Henderson detention center and this is
video of that facility six days later
authorities say his health started
declining while still in custody he died
at Sunrise Hospital later that day this
is the third homicide investigation in
Henderson this year